place un fond intox maintenant
bonsoir à vous Anthony Saint-Léger
bonsoir il y a quelques jours la
rédaction des Observateurs de France 24
à repérer une fausse Une de
l'hebdomadaire satirique français
Charlie Hebdo relayer en Russie les
questions de nazisme en Ukraine
effectivement la publication qui circule
depuis le 25 novembre dernier on y voit
deux hommes en kéfié qui s'interrogent
de la signification d'une inscription en
arrière-plan un début de graffiti nazi
réalisé par des supporters Ukrainiens au
Qatar ça vous rappelle peut-être quelque
chose effectivement c'est une fausse
information dont je vous parlais déjà il
y a avec quelques temps pour sur
justement c'est supporters ukrainiens et
ce faux graffiti et se faux reportage
d'Al Jazeera et d'ailleurs vous vous
reconnaissez ici la masse la mascotte
pardon du Mondial à laquelle a été
attribué une moustache d'Hitler alors
les légendes qui publient cette cette
fausse une ou disquo que en France aussi
le nazisme associé à l'Ukraine que
Charlie Hebdo a publié une édition
spéciale sur les aventures de ces nazis
Ukrainiens en Qatar en référence donc à
se faux épisodes concernant les
supporters c'est un montage de toutes
pièces puisque ce qui est présenté comme
étant le numéro
1584 de Charlie Hebdo n'existe tout
simplement pas sur le site de Charlie
Hebdo en effet le numéro
1584 du 30 novembre est consacré à
l'actualité politique française une
publication qu'on retrouve donc
majoritairement sur telegram
effectivement et majoritairement sur des
comptes favorables au Kremlin grâce à
tégestat qui permet d'analyser les
données sur telegram on apprend que
cette fausse une a été relayée par au
moins 85 groupes télégram russophone la
publication d'origine qui a été
supprimée depuis c'est celle-ci elle
date du 25 novembre elle vient d'une
chaîne télégramme ouvertement Poutine
alors cette une cette fausse une de
Charlie Hebdo n'est pas un cas isolé en
effet depuis juillet il on a eu au moins
6 vous en avez ici trois exemples 6
fausses une de Charlie Hebdo qui ont été
diffusés sur les réseaux sociaux russes
toutes liée de près ou de loin à la
guerre en Ukraine et d'ailleurs on voit
ici le président vaut l'audimir ski le
président ukrainien grimé en petit
toutou on reconnaît bien les codes la
typographie de l'hebdomadaire satirique
on reconnaît aussi ici même coco du nom
d'une des dessinatrices de Charlie Hebdo
on notera quand même toutefois certaines
fautes d'orthographe qui aurait pu
mettre la puce à l'oreille en tout cas
Charlie Hebdo a déjà alerté sur ce
phénomène de du prix en septembre sur
deux une en particulier sur son site des
unes qui sont très populaires sur le
réseau social telegram relayé par des
personnalités pro Kremlin de premier
plan comme par exemple et bien le
journaliste est présentateur de
télévision Vladimir qui est présenté ni
plus ni moins comme le propagandiste du
Kremlin et tout ça dans quel but Anthony
et bien il faut savoir avant tout que
Charlie Hebdo n'est pas le seul média
visé en effet depuis l'été dernier
depuis septembre plus précisément
plusieurs médias internationaux ont été
falsifiés d'après le média russe
indépendant je précise un média de
vérification proveréno c'est même une
bonne dizaine de médias internationaux
qui sont concernés un phénomène qui
n'est pas nouveau nous a confié qui est
plutôt nouveau pardon nous a confié le
rédacteur en chef de ce média la
stratégie qui est donc née durant l'été
il répondait aux questions d'Alexandre
Capron on va l'écouter
effectivement c'est publications elles
sont très populaires en Russie mais elle
recueille très peu de partage dans les
autres langues alors des stratégies
d'influence prorus et j'en finirai ici
similaire et bien il y en a eu par le
passé il y a eu de campagne de menées de
même pour dénigrer l'opposant numéro à
Vladimir Poutine Alexa il y a eu aussi
beaucoup plus récemment en novembre
dernier des caricatures politiques
utilisées par des comptes prorus pour
tenter d'influencer sur les résultats
des meeters ces élections de mi-mandat
aux États-Unis c'est ce que nous apprend
la société a rapport de la société
analytique Graphica des images qui
étaient liées à des
usines à troll en quelque sorte qui est
elle-même était lié à cet homme que vous
allez reconnaître le fondateur de Wagner
ieveny Prigogine merci beaucoup Antonio
pour trouver votre chronique sur vos
réseaux sociaux merci à vous leur
également et puis on va marquer une très
courte pause on se retrouve dans
quelques instants à tout de suite
[Musique]